okay hey everybody this is Eric Griffin
welcome to episode 9 of riffing with
Griffin it's a very special episode
because I'm now at all things comedy
this is my first episode at all Finn's
comedy that's announcement one
announcement - there's going to be my
first episode having a guest Lake
Anderson from workaholics welcome Blake
Anderson and Blake as you I don't know
if you know this but I don't have a
theme song and I keep trying to get a
theme song so I know I'm a huge fan and
I've been along for the journey
I love to hear that and guess what
somebody made me a theme song great kid
named Lamont Landers Lamont
and so here's if you want to do a theme
song please send it to me but here's
what Lamont Wright that was actually
very worth it that last note was it
wasn't the last note worth it Thank You
Lamont Landers you know I have some
links to Lamont and uh look for some
links to his stuff he's actually a
really cool nerdy white kid that's
unbelievable
with this soulful voice Wow nerds got
glasses is I didn't believe it when I
heard I was like are you gonna make me a
song then when I heard it I was like
damn little Javon to grow you come on
man Michael McDonald haulin oats there's
some soulful white guys out there wait
hold on Daryl Hall Hall & Oates are
soulful white guys yeah what you have
you ever listened to Hall & Oates okay
what's your favorite Hall & Oates song
hard to answer method to my love right
met em ETH OD o L o P o all right you
know what man I still you need to go
through the Hall & Oates catalog I swear
to god they are I didn't realize my own
breaking I don't know they I didn't
realize that they were this so is it
like starter soulful do you think well
they call it blue-eyed soul that's the
term and in the music industry I believe
and that's basically when white guys
make cool it's cool soul music that's
you know you realize that's so close to
blue-eyed devil I'm sure it started
there and then it got nicer as it had to
be publicized yeah well man I've known
you now for so many years I wanted you
to be my first guest because the reason
is is because when I went to that
audition for workaholics for the very
first time I remember I went a day early
you did I was a day early and you were
just walking around I was getting a
snack yeah
in our snack room in the that's when our
offices were in Burbank yeah that weird
you just took over like nowcasting or
whatever it was it's kind of awesome we
had at least had like a pretty dope
parking spot yeah yeah before we were
just in the blazing but yeah I remember
running into you in our little snack
room and I don't know you were kind of
like oh man I'm a day early or whatever
because I was like you were like no cuz
you said to me you were like are you
here for Montez and I was like yeah yeah
you were like that's tomorrow yes and
then I was so embarrassed at the times
like woah yeah oh you know in my mind
I'm thinking I'm just here scouting you
know before I well see but me I had that
small interaction with you and I ran
back to the writers room and I basically
was like guys I just met our montes you
heard it here first people and they're
like who is this guy I'm like I don't
know it's like this
bootleg Egyptian looking at Sinbad
okay let's tone it down but then I was
like who they were like who was I was
like his name was Eric Eric Griffin and
then I was like no no way no way we're
not getting there oh god you know what's
funny I Adam always hates when I I've
told this story so many times but I saw
him a week before and I didn't know that
he had this show in the works and so I
and I was giving him like that older guy
sage advice you know just keep keep
working buddy you gonna make it one day
type of thing then I walk into this
audition and I see him and I thought
although he's interning or something
like that was mr. Devine whatever you
know you wrote that first episode right
that I was in I'm credited I mean all
the episodes we wrote together and then
they kind of like draw names out of hats
to assign who gets what episode and mine
just so I technically own your character
oh I wrote that episode any break off
off shoot Montez show I will
be a producer on people ask me about
that all the time it would be awesome
yes this what would it be now I'd be
like 10 years after yeah you'd probably
come AmeriCorps clothes now he like
probably working in your own like you
run a section of telamericorp now
somewhere else like in the Caribbean
there's all sex toys oh there you go now
my question is when you wait when you
made the character Montez when you guys
were talking about I know it's based off
somebody that honors new write the name
may I believe I don't know so much that
but you you were the character yeah but
see the things I remember coming into
like the second audition where it was
like these are the people that have a
chance and I looked around and I was
like oh they don't know who this person
is yet cuz it was like half the room was
like black black yeah and then the other
half was like Latino yeah and then it
was like me and I was like okay I don't
know who what I could tell you didn't
know you know what you wanted at first
well I think we you know we always
wanted a diverse cast because well a
we're bringing three white guys to the
table so you got as you come with
foundation you know you've got to switch
it up a little bit but I know like with
the character of Montez yeah we kind of
wanted someone who you know it was kind
of just an odd person we wanted
everybody in the office to be kind of
real and when you are work in those kind
of places you meet the weirdest people
yeah so we kind of just knew that we
didn't want him to be sort of a tech
nerd yeah I felt like I was the leader
of the Nerds and that are the weird guys
and that when that crew especially when
I first met Jett said in Wainman yeah
totally but then we thought it would be
really funny if you were like hyper
sexual but completely 100% into your
wife as well because we wanted to have
that with those weird like sex stories
but it was always with your wife so it's
like you don't really want to hear this
bad just kind of an overshare ii that
was our first scene together yeah what
else well not well other than the bare
coat thing but I remember that was the
audition the audition was that 5 a.m.
yeah you know and it was like so much
longer laying the tarp laying the tarp
down and all that which I still get
people coming to me about baby oil and
stuff now yeah I remember that that was
the audition it was way
in the original script yeah I then when
it was time to shoot you guys are like
we're not gonna have eight pages of
Montes talking about [ __ ] his wife
yeah well that's why we need the show
the Montes show all right what I wanted
one of the things I wanted to ask you
about about workaholics do you think
that because there's such a dude show
you know was such a like about drinking
and all that kind of stuff and you know
women tits and all that do you think the
workaholics could have survived into
climate now um I think that the people
involved in that show us you know we're
smart enough to make it work I think we
would have found a way to make it work
for sure I mean it was definitely a
different climate back then and when you
go back and watch some of the things
you're like geez like no way you could
even come close to me and that was only
like five six years ago it's crazy right
the comedic landscape has just been a
bizarre lately yeah but I mean you know
we were just in there trying to make the
funniest show possible
like just going for the jokes we went
for the jokes yes too hard yeah I
remember I had to be naked yeah lots of
nudity that's kind of our brand yeah but
I had to be thank you I remember even
asking you I was like I said just Montez
is naked I said are you sure you were
like hey man that's been in the script
for a long time all right so I don't
know yeah we didn't specifically write
an episode to see you naked
oh yeah I didn't come in to you guys
like oh no that was not on the agenda oh
man what was your do do you miss it
like do you miss doing workaholics um I
think what I didn't realize is how much
workaholics was keeping me in touch with
the dudes like you know like you kind of
take it for granted when you see guys
every single day for seven eight years
and then when you don't have that job to
go to it's just you know it's especially
it's the nature like this biz that
people just kind of yeah it's like
summer camp when you
a job and you think like we're gonna be
best friends forever I mean we're all
still best friends it's just you know
people have families and work takes you
to different cities and just getting
together that's I know I probably I see
Adam more than you see Adam now right
or even like there are writers that we
work with and like all those people and
everybody else in the cast you just you
just know that I am me too is a group of
people yeah that that was like some of
the funnest times just like even in the
early years and yet like a little shitty
office with these crazy little dressing
rooms and yeah you know just dealing
with like just how we shot it was I felt
like we were doing a student film at
first I mean kind of well when you think
about it we didn't have any sort of like
that on set we were all kind of just
like this our first swing at this let's
have fun this is a dream job we were all
doing what we came here to do so there
just wasn't any kind of egos or anything
we just kind of just yeah I always I my
favorite episode to this day is still
off his campout mm-hmm because to me it
like epitomized what the show was about
yeah you three just doing your thing and
I always tell people watch workaholics
in Reverse it gets funnier true I mean a
lot of those like early episodes I feel
like could it be just movie premises you
know well you they like what actually
was a movie premise right totally you
walk in being in that vent was the
inspiration for the yeah the Netflix
movie yeah totally do you ever find it
weird that people still they they saw
that movie and they still call it the
workaholics movie yeah I mean it's but I
don't blame them I mean it's pretty like
on brand like we kind of just slightly
pivoted it's still like that dude
centric humor and cutting off dicks and
all that blown up dogs yeah we didn't
really like push ourselves to some
different characters or anything like
that funny thing about the movie Kyle
calls me you know he says Eric I want
you to be in this movie and I go all
was down I'll say let's do it he'd go
whoa whoa wait wait a minute let me
before you say yes let me tell you what
you have to do so he wanted me to come
and be the guy getting his ass eaten by
the bad guy Jon Gabrus did he knocked it
out of the park but we would love to
have that sure that would have been
hilarious people would have been so
pumped on seeing you get your booty and
you would have been very funny you know
it oh yeah me like whoa I'm gonna like
it I'm still giggle thinking about yeah
but I was like it's the funniest scene
in the movie age so I said to him then
you should do it well I also thought
that was a very good idea yeah he should
have done it right but that's like nasty
like for some reason I don't see him get
it so meet me it's funny he had a nice
baby baby dude Kyle oh yeah I don't know
I don't know what you got I for some
reason I'm envisioning you with a quite
a pristine ass but Kyle's just seems
like with these knuckles you think my
ass yeah that would've been funny too
and seeing him sick
I always thought though that if you guys
were to like continue you didn't you
don't have to be on call me central you
doesn't even have to be called
workaholics I mean it's such a strong
brand you guys I don't know I mean you
guys had the chemistry you guys have was
just it was just undeniable it's
palpable you could feel it and if you
guys went to CBS and you guys were
working as truck drivers people would be
like oh man workaholics just on the CBS
and they're driving trucks now like what
do you feel about like that chemistry
that you guys had I mean how do you keep
saying hat I mean we're still like you
just got finished saying like I'm a dad
no dad I don't see them we're still
plugging away on like movies and stuff
that's true you might say you just did
the movie that's right you guys are
still great what am I talking it well
it's weird like that came out the
beginning this year it feels like it
came out ten years ago yeah but like as
far as like the workaholics chemistry or
whatever like the only thing that ever
intrigued me CBS would definitely be
weird because we'd have to like make it
a family show or whatever but like
taking it to like a HBO or something
like that where we could
let me get the dogs out that I was
always like that could be kind of fun
yeah there there we making all these
shows anyway out if Netflix called we
want to do a buck while season of
workaholics 13 episodes you guys want to
come back for one season would you do it
I I wouldn't yeah I would for sure why
not well you heard it here first this
kid that this make that happened yeah I
mean yeah but I don't know cuz I could
just see him I felt like you guys were
trying to torture me I mean there was an
episode where I had to eat boogers and I
want a real butter he doesn't matter but
I specifically remember you coming out
to be talked about I can't wait okay I
mean I like to see you squirm but you
can't say that we didn't put ourselves
through the same kind of torture that's
true
we were like you guys went you went for
it there are several times on set where
we were like why do we write these
things why don't we just make our lives
easy why are we going through mud
everything why are we covered in blood
why are we having fish food fight like
why does it always stink on set why we
got rats all over it's like yeah
remember Adam had to tackle me that one
episode he has done coordinator comes
over says Erik just make sure you
breathe out I was like what that was it
that was the whole and then action here
comes Adam storming around the corner
full-on decks me in the belly yeah he
was taking out some aggression yeah he
was a little bastard yeah he always like
he always like then everything we do
after that it's always the same
interaction now even if it's even if
it's Montez and Adam from the show or if
it's Erik and Adam it's the same thing
you go gold you dude he's just
projecting he truly loves you all right
he sleeps with a Erik Griffin body
pillow but to say well we just patented
it that would be a really comfy pillow I
see you just call me fat right on my
show what a what comfy pillow
man I want to lay on you so how's life
for you as a dad that's what I want to
know I can't even believe you're a dad
you have an adorable daughter
thank you very much um it's it's crazy
it's me it's it's mind-blowing but it's
awesome yeah I mean it's like it's all
the cliches you hear anybody ever say
and it just it's a total mental
readjustment you can't get with him
ladies you know I used to get sick of I
used to be on the road all the time well
I'm not married man oh I still I'm still
car walking I used to I used to all the
time I would like if I do to college I
would open up the floor and be like all
right guys any questions it was always
your step Blake's real hair can I get
his number could we call them yeah you
know I always got my favorite one was
always [ __ ] marry kill I would get that
a lot for about you guys that it's
always it's never like unanimous I feel
like that all changes up depending on no
I was answered the same yeah yeah
I would kill Adam and I would marry
Anders because he's responsible you just
said you wanted to lay on me
that is not sexual I just want the
comfort of your warm
hey cushiony body things happen in the
thralls
how did you get here at this point you
had this in your notes
okay whatever is uh are you gonna let
your daughter watch workaholics
eventually at what point you're gonna be
like you could watch this yeah I I guess
I have to go back and re-watch see how
bad they are
yeah oh you just like it's all bleep
they're like it's really like six-minute
long episodes cuz you like yeah you
can't see dissing that I don't mind all
the crazy stuff but it it was a pretty
hyper sexual show yeah I definitely
would not want to watch it with like
your parents in the room or anything
Colin oh wow
imagine you're gonna be that guy I like
you're gonna be like that you're gonna
be like hey turn it off yeah hell are
you Annoying Orange that some [ __ ] kid
[ __ ] is weird
yeah like kid shows but now kids just
watch like unboxing videos have you ever
seen that [ __ ] it's ridiculous and then
you see they have like six million views
of just like a little kid opening up a
doll I don't know what it is doing to
these kids might but it there they love
it he's hypnotizing you haven't gotten
hypnotized you haven't just had a video
on like that and been like I've been
watching this for 25o their voices are
always the worst I hate their cadence I
hate the words they use I hate the way
they say it's like it's always terrible
like oh my god oh yeah it's a like a
adult babies like it's I never see kids
unwrapping it's always like an adult but
they never show their faces it's really
weird it's odd it's really weird and
like but some of them like some of the
videos like I have my buddy of my house
three kids and he won't like for
instance he won't let his kids watch
Logan Paul videos anymore oh yeah it was
something about because he was like he
does these pranks in public yeah does
these mean things in public so his kids
were like there's a disconnect because
they think YouTube is like well this is
real even though they don't know that
some people on there it's fake or
they're just doing a character yeah all
that stuff is like trash to me like
what's your what's your YouTube thing
Dodie have some that you go to because
right now I'm watching chiropractor
videos oh I don't know why but like
it'll be like a kid comes in it'll say
like you know he's had pain for five
years and then this guy does some you
know what and then I watch like - like
the loudest crack like montages that's
gonna turn into like a weird kink for me
you think I don't know
yeah man you don't want to know about
that I also like blackheads and like the
pimple popping yeah my new other one is
earwax
what yeah that's the best why why would
you watch that what is your best it's
like q-tip sorry no it's like they go to
the doctor and the in and they got the
camera and they're looking inside the
ear and it's just disgusting and then
they clean it out and they pull out like
a golf ball of wax and when that but
when that when that wax comes out the
ear you're just at home like yes I mean
watch YouTube at all what's your thing I
just watched like sports that's how I
watch it's like reality TV yet its
finest what are you just watching
basketball i watch a lot of basketball
yeah watch baseball when it's on I've
never been a baseball guy you it's one
of those things where I think you have
to be fully in or you're just all the
way out I was that like from your
childhood you'd like to baseball uh yeah
for a while just cuz like you know I
grew up like East Bay so the A's
they're like tickets were super cheap
and you hop on BART and it was just kind
of a way of like just getting out with
your home he's hanging out at the
baseball game for a couple hours did you
want to play baseball or were you
athletic at all yeah it was fairly
athletic baseball I was kind of bad at
that was like one of my first like
childhood scars is like I was being bad
at baseball yeah cuz I there was this
kid on my team whose name was will Clark
which is like a it was on the Giants oh
there was a guy named will Clark right
right his kid's name on my team was will
Clark and he was really good and I
wasn't so good and I remember every time
I would like go out to bat I'd hear him
in the dugout be like oh here comes
another out oh my god bully yeah I'm
like oh yeah I suck at sucking my
teammates hate me he's it was just like
mmm and then I was afraid of getting hit
with pitches cuz it is kind of crazy
that they just let like kids throw away
because their accuracy is not there at
all they're terrible that's the first
time you do we rack up to got wear a cup
that is weird yeah like yeah it's just a
pizza so you weren't so you you try but
somebody played though like how long did
you play baseball for this was in high
school
no no come on you think he would shake
me that hard in high school how do me
like [ __ ] will Clark okay
I'll excuse me into an improv please
like your school the improv kids were
the bullies you guys were like that this
is like we ran [ __ ] you would yeah we
and we ran [ __ ] devil mountain improv
Lee what's up champions
trophies so alright so this was in like
middle school is like back in the day
yeah maybe even before that I quit
baseball pretty quick cuz I was just
shook so that's it I played more like
soccer that was being in football I went
to one football tryout yeah I went to
one football tryout the ball hit me in
two fingers yeah yeah it was like and I
was like I'm out two things the ball hit
me in two fingers and the coach yelled
at me because I I you know yet did run a
route and drop the ball three times in a
row on the third time I I went like this
whoa yeah and then the fourth time I
jammed my finger and I was like I'm out
time the coach actually had put hands on
if the that's what it would have been so
I didn't play but you didn't know
football basketball ball I I played like
basketball with my friends but I if I
could go back I would have at least
tried to be on the basketball team oh
really
you thought you regret I guess I regret
that but then again I was pretty small
up until like last year yeah I was a
really late bloomer you want yeah
my nickname in high school was afro
fetus because I had an afro and my body
was very underdeveloped you look like
Stewie from Family Guy yeah there's like
some improv I was playing some game
after school like at improv practice and
I end up taking my shirt off or like the
scene and then it was like that when it
was like did you see flakes blobby it's
just feet aisle
so you went so you tried to play
baseball that didn't work out you get
into high school you're not you're not
into sports you immediately went for the
Arts um yeah well you know I grew up
with Kyle right right right
Carl from workaholics and
kind of mean to check yeah it was kind
of me him in like six other dudes and we
were like a super tight click like
brothers or whatever but we were always
you know into like making home movies
like videos and stuff so we kind of just
saw that as the lane like create
creating stuff whether it be like
claymation z-- or short films or
whatever really yeah so this is an
example of yes so you literally lived
your dream yeah man and then moved I've
started with Kyle so to have him like
directing me the whole way through it's
it's it's really quite surreal when you
think about it yeah me too me cause
actually he was my first real director
like you know that was the first time I
was on a set like that was more Cox is
my big break
yeah man and he's he's done he just put
me you know he just put me in a dis
antler movie yeah and he knocked I mean
I can't wait to see how me to is like it
was like a huge big-budget their biggest
budget they've ever did for our Sandler
movie so and he was like up there just
doing I was it was great to see him in
his element unreal and everybody has
nothing but good stuff to say about him
I think he just is yeah he's just really
good at his job
all right so no sports you went into the
arts then did you did you go to college
I did I went to Orange Coast Community
College
so you didn't go to college and then I'm
a member of the Hall of Fame so I did it
pretty damn good yeah but were you the
Hall of Fame after you left or after you
guys I got inducted with Adam this year
Adam but I did transfer from there to
CSULB Long Beach alright okay but then I
got the show and I dropped out really
yeah I didn't know that yeah look at
that and then Adam but Adam had already
decided he wasn't gonna yes can Adam
quit school Kyle quit school yeah but I
was wondering when you guys made you
guys made the firt the original pilot
you guys made it yourselves right like
with Kyle's equipment that kind of thing
right yes well we did that like initial
like it was like a five episode like web
series that was kind of loosely based on
what would become workaholics but then
you know we went and pitched
Comedy Central and they like the idea so
they gave us a little some money for for
the pilot so it wasn't a lot of money so
we definitely were pulling in some
favors yeah yeah I don't know have you
ever seen like the original pilot that's
like kind of slightly different from no
I never saw the I got a just like
Alice's not the same yes I have seen
that yes but it's it's like same line
yeah yeah yeah yeah so we poop dollar
all that yeah it's all in there wayman's
in there wayman's day one er because he
was a he was a Craigslist right yes from
back in the day he was even in the
little five episode web series Wow
that's how far back way he's from the
very beginning oh man like day one
Wayman was day one damn I didn't know
this this is great inside workaholics
information and the wingman was day one
day one like nobody you can't go further
back than Wayman I I remember when I got
to call that I got to show it was only
four episodes so I always used to when I
would watch season one the camera would
pass by Montez desk
and I'd be like where the [ __ ] is Montez
he just not at work today maybe that's
what the the show is the spin-off like
we just go back in time this is where he
was during this and then you could have
it kind of like cross yeah yeah that's
cool I used to tweet out at the time
like all Montez had to dentist today
everybody you just missed it was a great
episode I bet I'd love to see that yeah
I'm sure the dentist that's gold
so you all right so then all right you
got then obviously Comedy Central's like
we love this and then the rest is
history
yeah so it was weird we kind of had to
like shop for shot reshoot that pilot
try to hit the same jokes right you guys
did yeah I remember I remember being
like oh man the old ones away fun here
but now when you watch it it's like the
old ones pretty bad was the show yeah
hell yeah I got you the show yeah I I
don't know I I look back I mean I look
back on like that that first season and
I just think I remember actually go back
even further when I first read the
script I just I thought wow
they're gonna let someone say this on
television that was the first thing I
thought then I thought lattices I don't
know if this is gonna last
yeah and then it's incredible how that
show is people's favorite show to this
day like is that weird for you the type
of think of this like Fame but it's like
a like it's a it's a weird cult II type
of Fame well I think it's just because
like we were really not that we were
targeting it but we were like hitting
people at ages and demographics when
they're super impressionable and like
they you know for some reason we had
this magical grasp on people or they
like really felt like they were friends
with us and like you know so then you
start to get people were like oh man you
like raise me through my high school or
college years or I'll be like oh you're
just like my buddy
yeah such as such yeah or yeah you're
him I'm here yeah like that's just how
you know it was resonated and really
relatable and all that so I think part
of it is you guys were using your real
names too yeah like so that was like
there was like a disconnect that people
didn't realize that this isn't real you
know like I had to tell people all the
time like they would ask questions like
I would you question it's probably call
you Montez oh I sometimes I'm like
actually just officially changed my
middle name - Montez just cuz like I
don't I don't pay it any mind anymore
yeah I don't want to be like what's his
name you know from Superbad or what
anyway every time they call him that
he's like that's not me you know people
get pissed
no I don't I get it yeah I get at me cuz
the way people are about it I get it em
I think it's so excited and it's just
like like your your my whoever follows
me on social media you're the number one
did they like the most suite of like I
could know I just know because when I
put a picture up if I put a picture with
Adam I get a lot of fun I get a lot of
like likes but nothing like when it's
you well I guess it's cuz you know I
created your character here we go and
they know that you came from me
you're not my dad TV dad now that's a
show yeah I adopt you that's kind of
cool guys I want you to meet my son he's
48 40-ish and I cuddle him at night
oh man so let's talk about how my
Clippers are you you really want to use
this time to talk about the Los Angeles
Clippers yeah man what do you want to
talk about we're talking about how
they're beating the Golden State
Warriors right down the standings I'm
gonna just have this guy just had this
moment you can I'm just telling you when
you're this podcast comes out it's
probably not gonna be this thing doesn't
come on have you always been a Warriors
man yeah I mean growing up in the Bay
Area you've got of course so then you
understand how it is to be a Clippers
fan cuz the boys have been bad for most
of your life oh yeah they were they were
really bad but there's a you always find
stuff to cling to
but that's where like I mean think I'm
stoked for the Clippers being good this
season because I was like oh really no
oh yeah but I was like really bummed on
him before the season started I was like
jumped for you guys like your squad is
just like corny like you have nobody but
they've been doing a pretty good job of
like ah lucky reluctantly you have to
say that Tobias seems like a super nice
dude in BO bond for whatever oh yeah but
you know he's funny and he's cool he's
like he's dunking on fools but I'm just
like there's just nobody I'm like do
they don't we're all I guess they need
like the the NBA you have to have that
guy somebody that you're just like I'm
just saying even just skill wise like I
think Tobias Harris is great but if he's
like the third best player on a team
that's got like LeBron and Kyrie he's
like a Kevin Love he's like you know he
can't be the he's the best player on our
team and that's not gonna get you will
maybe I mean I don't know even Luiz
coming on we got a great bench we got
Beverley coming off the bench you always
say the same thing dude great bench
great pitch that's good for you such a
hater I'm not a hater yeah you have this
Vail hate right well all of my hate for
the
Clippers has faded because for a while
there yes I hated ballers dude that year
when we were up 20 in the first half up
20 you dad was the 70 to win season I
thought this is gonna be it the Clippers
are actually ready to make this happen
see that's we're taking the champ stand
we weren't ready we just we weren't
ready to be good no dude the Clipper
Clipper history is just wild you guys
were right there there were they're like
I know how it is cause like even like
going back to like being a A's fan there
were these seasons where it's like this
is the year where if it's gonna happen
it's gonna happen at least the A's have
a history of winning this was like the
Clippers have no history of winning
their to borderline curse to be
considered like oh you might actually
the word championship and Clippers were
set in the same sentence that year squad
looked good but then what happened Chris
Paul likes his lower half exploded or
upper half it's like all on and then
like glutens knees would explode he just
would disappear in the fourth quarter or
didn't he punched a guy broke yeah they
just it that's why I'm amazed that we
lose three guys that are like considered
really upper echelon superstar type
players and for us to be in the Western
Conference and like right there in the
thick of it it's like I mean that's
that's my championship right yeah you
guys were well yeah that's just I think
the organization started to get a little
poisonous the last few seasons and now
they just have all that weight off their
shoulders and they're like let's just
play ball he took the thing away from
Doc he's now just a coach yeah they took
Austin Rivers away from dogs
yeah me think I was like happy come on
talk about nepotism but anybody wouldn't
you do that too if you were coaching a
WNBA team and you're your daughters
Marlin and you wouldn't you be like I
gotta give her a 17 like we don't like
your daughter she's destroying the team
she's taking really bad shots at the end
of the game she thinks she's good as
[ __ ] that's not great she's really not
great yeah I would I see with people so
how would you take that like it would be
a it would be a tough position
sure yes I I totally understand I'm
never mad at doc for giving his son a
contract where he was making more money
than some of the starters the only
reason I could be mad is because I truly
think it completely screws ever had
choice there was like a moment like with
that whatever that trade was Chris Paul
would have still been on the team Austin
Rivers wasn't on the day yeah but you
weren't you guys gonna get like Carmelo
or something any Squatch well this was a
couple seasons ago so he might have had
a little more juice in the tank I don't
think so
I think five seasons ago he was done
poor Melo I know what's going I mean I
don't even know where he's playing now I
think he's gonna come back I think he's
gonna go overseas why he's already made
all that money he got his money well I
mean somewhere like cool like he'll go
to like Puerto Rico that's how was that
cool what do you think it'd be cool to
play me Carmelo and Puerto Rico yeah man
no he's married with kids is he still
married yes he's still married to Lala
is he yeah you think she's going to
Puerto Rico with their kids why he's
playing well exactly so he's about to be
killing it are you saying that he would
leave the wife you know are the king at
king of Puerto Rico yeah just pina
coladas he just has to have play nice I
see why your melot melot melot knows
what's up
I don't know you were a Pisces I don't
know why I didn't know that yeah man
come on what are you March I'm March
12th March 2nd we're very close yeah
we've had this bond for so many years
how come we didn't have like dual
birthdays on set I don't because really
you really want to know why why come on
you guys I created you you don't get a
birthday unless I write it I own you you
guys were a little bit of divas you guys
were divas yeah especially towards the
later seasons you just need to know it
all right
dete how so how deep and what was deep
yes come on no one sets I've been on
sets yes we are I realized what I went
on other sets we all wear the deep
looks like oh these guys rodillas you're
out of your mind
we we shared a freaking trailer our
whole life we didn't we were stand-ins
for we didn't have standings our first
few seasons I always remember this like
so if there's a scene between with me
and you guys is you three here uh-huh if
it's just like this yeah this is how it
would be behind me and be like two-shot
Blake and Adam Blake an honors Blake
Adam and Anders crane shot you know up
inside swing shot swindle Twingo
whatever that other stupid terminology
is you know you know four hours later
then it's like all right turn around on
Montez three takes out I'm right we got
it so it up we got it movin on up and
you should be happy I wrote you those
lines just cuz we had offices you could
say we're divas I'm only to you okay
look look how sensitive he is
you people don't know that man is really
since that sensitive man yeah I know
we're both Pisces both sensitive Pisces
I just better be nice when he you tell
people I'm a diva I hear you on other
podcast speaking dirt on my name I mean
nothing but good to you
another but good to you I always say
you're my favorite you know then I get
calls from Adam about it you know I know
well maybe we are divas you got a really
nice I mean are you happy with a I mean
I mean when you look and see where were
the other two guys have gone from here I
mean is it these are like a sense of
pride for you I do you know what do you
feel about like what's going on with
Adam you know hundra's honest when he
had to show and he's going dude you know
champions for his billboards were
everywhere for that was crazy like
seeing ders on like cuz I'm right by
these studios so I would just have to
see his fat head everywhere is it now is
there like a sibling rivalry with you
guys though is there a part of you guys
there like when you left did you guys
look at each other like I'm gonna be
bigger than you
it was there a little bit of that I I
would say if ever I had that it was more
at the beginning of everything and then
now it's like that's just oh you're a
dad now you're all well it's just not
there's enough stuff out here for
everybody and I think we all like we
don't really compete for roles we're all
kind of like different character types
it'd be different if it was like what if
you did walk into an audition or you
walk into a way they said we need you to
read you walk in and it's a demand on
there so they're sitting there and you
guys are all going for the same part oh
there's definitely been times where I've
been like yeah I got this audition for
this and then there's we'll be like oh I
went in for that now I'd be like oh well
you're obviously gonna get it they're
already like asking if I'll cut my hair
and oh my god ah but I get that about my
mustache will you shave your mind every
single - they said will you save your
mustache and I always say you wouldn't
want me to shave yeah I would look
ridiculous right yeah I don't know are
you ever gonna cut your hair is that
ever gonna be a thing were you gonna be
like would you what role would you cut
your hair for or who what would the
circumstances be like it's got to be
Spielberg this has got to be like you
know who is a really like Spielberg
would work with me I don't I don't know
I'm like I've been thinking about it
more lately I guess I guess that's just
cuz I've kind of been sitting on my butt
but like it's like there's things you
can do with wigs and stuff but yeah I'm
also just like well if it's that great
army role there looks like you you're
you know you you know you yes yes I'm
not it's like it's one of those like you
know I'm into that yeah it's like a
Golden Globe performance type of thing
would you shave your head I feel like
for sure or like I'd be totally down
like if it was like a Metallica biopic
to get like a sick like Metallica mullet
or something
I feel like I have to go like mullet
with bangs before I go fully or I just
want to shave it so you what I'm saying
you would know there is a but it has to
be a passion project I think so it's not
gonna be some dumb comedy is not gonna
be some rom-com or they gonna be like
hey we shave you here you like no yeah
not rated because this is good yeah
that's my other thing I've been looking
for a place to get my hair braided
been a long time done it like I do you
want to get cornrow braids yeah Oh some
Dookie rolls
yeah hook me up didn't you have it in
the show Juggalo episode yeah yeah
that's back when Carla farmer was our ho
called our hair girl Carla was on I'm
dying up here Oh was she she was the
season - she was the head of hair it was
like full circle man oh man I haven't
seen her she was awesome yeah Carla was
great oh yeah she should go along
without him but maybe not as picky about
that hair yeah yeah I think I don't know
if you're a Harry Potter nerd or not oh
well I'm a Harry Potter nerd so they all
they always had like in every book there
was a new Defense Against the Dark Arts
teacher because it was cursed right I
felt like the first five seasons of
workaholics the hair person was cursed
yeah cuz it was like it was a new hair
person every single year until you
settled on yeah I think just went on
bigger better stuff and then well yeah
we had rowdy there for a while and now
we didn't go kind of found found our
match found you found you the love of
your workaholics life yeah um I don't
know where we're at right now man I
think we're is that like an hour how
long we been talking Oh 45 kg yeah are
you not going anywhere yet I just want
to make sure um I don't know man I I
feel like you are doing some great
things I feel like where do you see
yourself like after this I mean like you
know cuz you're in you're still in your
30s so like like what's next for Blake
Anderson what do you like you still want
to act and then you still get you still
have the clothing company you have
teenage still got that which I mean I
never got my fries thing
I never got my double double X shirt
yeah man promised me for five years yeah
you're slick about pushing me off your
specialty sighs man it's got a feel oh
you don't make boy sizes offering cute
white kids oh come on now no I think we
get up there but I just I just wanted
you to pay for it I don't give out
freebies man come on you're the worst
that's called a good business man I
don't think jay-z gave out free C I'm
sure he did I don't know with boys you'd
have to ask Oh Mike especially he wrote
the rhymes for the you know he put him
on the label I'm sure that what you did
yeah I guess you're right so let's so
you still have the company
yeah I'm still doing stuff with teenage
um I have like there's an Adult Swim
cartoon that I worked on produced did
some voices wrote on call big tone that
comes out in January I believe mm-hmm
yeah which I'm stoked on that's like my
first cartoon that have really start to
finish I didn't get a call for any
voices hopefully we get a season two
will get you oh you had a whole season
one yeah well the whole season there's
people who don't have other saying don't
give me don't give me that
now you take maybe demoting yourself all
of a sudden I really have no say in who
gets what part do cartoons yeah I've
done cartoons I do tons you have like an
amazing cartoon voice uh you have
amazing cartoon face here we go
everybody
what man it's beautiful yeah cartoon
stuff is fun I know it's easy I did like
Harvey beaks on Nickelodeon mm-hmm I did
that I did Bob's Burgers cool yeah I was
their accountant nice and they drew that
the character it looked like me of
course I don't know if you're not
supposed to do that but what was I gonna
complain so you're not supposed to do
that one oh they can't draw your
likeness if they draw your likeness they
have to pay you extra for though really
yeah well did you shake the tree were
you like where my money yeah
no the key was just like they were just
this is Bob's Burgers so you can get a
couple more bucks
ah Alec that was a huge huge cartoon
like that like everything around
it was like so big I was like wow
there's cartoon world dude when you get
a cartoon that hits its oh my god I know
money in the bank I want to be quagmire
or somebody like that are real you know
I mean I always thought why didn't we
ever do
why didn't they just make workaholics a
cartoon forever to call me Central's
weird man we tried we gave it a shot we
were like we could do this animated just
never came down the pipe what you think
your relationship ended badly ended
badly no I think we all left on good
terms I just talking about you guys in
the powers-that-be of course know me and
the dudes were yeah you guys are holdin
like no I I think I think we ended on
good terms with Comedy Central I was
just yeah I don't know I was just I was
surprised with how they handled the
whole network yeah I think the [ __ ] on
them but I was just like they everybody
kind of left yeah what's going on oh
there's supposed to be the safeguards of
comedy yeah it's supposed to be
centralized you know I think this place
I mean it could have something to do
with what we're saying like just the
comedy landscape has been so confusing
maybe they were scrambling to rebrand
themselves or whatever but I think is
also just like they just wanted to be
like an incubator and then let their
babies off into the world it seems like
what they did where it's like the four
side I would say try to hold on to some
of your I think that I think the were
kollek's would still be on the air what
would you have wanted to do that though
because this would have been like the
tenth season would you have wanted to
get to ten or is at a certain point you
were like I gotta go on and do something
else well one thing was well for a while
we were chasing that like syndication
number and then stupidly we'd never even
realized that Comedy Central doesn't
syndicate so you're really just you're
setting your own bar like where how long
do you want to go all right because you
there's I forget what then it's been a
while now but there's a certain number
you have to hit to where you can like
sell a show on another network to
syndicate and we hit that but yeah yeah
but they were like we're not gonna we
don't want eyes off our network yeah
yeah they were just like no no we're
gonna keep it here and just play it to
the certain amount where we don't have
to pay any residual
exactly like if a tea let's say like if
they play it 88 turns that give
residuals they knew they would only play
it
yeah they got they got the business
model down they know what they're doing
I love getting those like $3 Internet
checks from workaholics yeah I like
gigolos in his life
$3.75 somewhere oh I did it's funny cuz
we you know we'd put in like random
friends into some episodes and they
still get those checks in yeah that's
cool yeah I mean it's a cool thing I
mean I don't know is it still on Comedy
Central I do they still just randomly
play it I don't even know I don't know
either
i from time to time it it comes on cuz I
know it's on like Hulu or Never
I can't even keep track of where they
put it on one year was on Netflix and
then it was off a Netflix that blew us
up that blew us up we got a big numbers
jump and then Viacom pulled all their
stuff off of Netflix that was a while
ago though that's a while and yet I just
thought that was a mistake
oh they yeah I mean yes me too but well
I think it's I think it's on Hulu as
well yeah I think it's on Hulu and
that's still pretty big I mean guess I
think what I like is how people are
still finding it people are finding it
like it's like it's new or something I'm
starting to like I've been noticing like
in Twitter mentions people going back
and watching it again yeah it's like
getting to be that time where it's like
well even me I was like over at Adams
talking to him and we were trying to we
were just going through like episodes
just being like like some were like
stompers what you would then what what's
your face what's your favorite did you
have like a top three do you like a
three that you go these are the ones
that I'll always remember
oh I mean it's pretty much blur but
though I really like um business trip
the one where we like take acid and go
with Mary Beth to like seal the deal
wasn't in that episode yeah we were but
that one was that one was cool I really
like that I really loved what is the
name I think it's called good morning
the one where homegirl dies and she has
the wake at the oh my god really love
that I would I you know I always tell
people they don't know that when an
extra could be so annoying that the
creators create a writer episode where
they kill her
well that's what was cool about our show
is like if you kind of just didn't
invite her back to be in the background
people probably wouldn't even even
notice I know but you guys like nah
let's kill right I always remembered
that episode because we had that was the
one we had to wake mm-hmm
and I remember Adam was doing all yeah
yeah yeah that was that was when he he
was that was so funny I remember
laughing during the whole take and he
goes interesting choice Erik to laugh
though yeah yeah I was like I thought we
were rehearsing
yeah him and Jillian he's gonna see
Jillian doing a good [ __ ] - yeah I
really you know Julian a long time -
right well yeah she goes back even
before workaholics cuz we used to do
like sketch comedy at this place
Hollywood in Highland and it's called
comedy cocktail and she was in another
sketch group and we were kind of like we
need we need to rope her up get her in
our videos isn't it crazy how sketch
groups are gone
and it's just all people are doing
videos yeah it's like a whole genre is
just gone do you know people to do
sketches I'm trying to think of like a
sketch group I don't know it's Kate
because even if there is a sketch group
they're still there on YouTube I think
what I'm seeing now or maybe not now but
like you know you follow like certain
like Instagram accounts because that's
where I guess you watch yeah basically
sketches now at this Instagram videos
yeah they're never too good but you
start to see like certain popular
instagramers being each other's videos
yeah and that's kind of like the new
that's the new thing that's what I'm
saying that's like your sketch group so
I remember I remember having did you
ever have shows when you were doing
sketches then when you guys were coming
up did you guys ever like get a theater
and then have people come watch you yeah
totally - I was a sketch group called
the suckling pigs that is such a bad
name Wow that's what you had what was
your guys's name mail-order common
that was originally from the beginning
that was wow we have such a cool moon we
did wasn't cool it's terrible it was
great
it's at least you know mo see if you can
abbreviate it yeah we couldn't do so
suckling no we can pigs yes you guys
suck pigs no but we used to do these
shows we had these little crazy theatres
in Hollywood you know we thought about
yeah we used to go this place called
like the West Side eclectic in like
Santa Monica yes
and then we just get a garbage can fill
it with beer and ice invite friends yeah
no one does that anymore comedy no one
does it nobody's like does live
performance anymore how they do that
like UCB and stuff yeah but that doesn't
count pretentious [ __ ] doesn't count
you think it's pretty I mean after
everything I've been a while I wish I
know I'm always like kicking myself I'm
like man I wish I was more involved or
like more out there seeing comedy shows
but then you like think about it's like
yeah where the [ __ ] are they yeah we're
do it cuz this understand up yeah but
it's like you're stand up stand up you
have to be in a mood for that yeah yeah
but sometimes you're just in the mood to
see like like like a play any play
people cuz people is crazy mind like you
know I love watching somebody they go
that this group thought of this like
whatever it might be you know you
interested in that it just people just I
don't know if people are doing they can
I don't always want to watch it on a
screen yeah just want to go live and see
this feel to it is my performance is
different I want to say UCB does do some
stuff I remember I saw one show there
that was called like dad quest and it
was like this whole kind of like funny
play about these dads that went into
like almost like a neverending story
world but it was all alive I was like
this is exactly what I'm talking about
I guess The Groundlings does it to The
Groundlings are still doing that they do
sketch I think they do sketch haven't
been there in for me either I just I'm
not I'm not necessarily affinis improv
I'm not an improv fan like if people are
just doing love improv but oh I can see
it can be really bad it can be it see
yeah there's no middle ground
improv is like a child actor they're
either great yeah or Anakin Skywalker
yeah I mean wait those are both great oh
no come on baby
you can tomatoes that's my [ __ ]
do you like and if you like he was the
worst the [ __ ] podracer scene is I'll
take that over like half more than half
of what Star Wars franchise puts out now
okay I want the [ __ ] podraces I
I'll just listen to the pod racing
sounds that's how dope it was like that
was revolutionary in sound yeah but you
want Jar Jar Binks back yes go back and
watch it jar jar's actually pretty cool
have you seen I'm trying to find the one
with somebody cut him out of the movie
and it's like so it's only like 45
minutes and it's a better movie that's
blasphemous you know the Star Wars
universe without [ __ ] Jar Jar
Binks okay that's the homie right there
ladies and gentlemen I want to thank Wow
standing up for Jar Jar Binks
yeah I can't we can't go further after
Jar Jar Jar Binks let me watch it
Jar Jar he's got something laughs yeah
but let me ask you this what can you
without weed would you feel the same way
well now what makes you think that we'd
to influence that decision in any way I
will say though Jar Jar probably smokes
big blinds Jar Jar sighs blood see they
could if they just added weed to charge
our storyline he'd be like the number
one character if he was just always like
[Music]
they would make all sins yeah but then
you would have to hand out weed at the
movies we're not too far from that yeah
we're getting close
yeah that's actually a great I may not
made a what I'm a weed movie do they do
that
oh we need to we need to get on this now
cuz I always thought if I didn't I was
like a weed record store would be really
cool but a weed movie theater yeah all
in this snack place would just be off to
change you'd have to have a waitress
just walking around that's a really good
idea yeah what hot dogs if people would
just be like it would be non-stop it'd
be like I'm seeing dr. strange again
[Laughter]
three times today gets better every time
people just don't leave the theaters
what would happen yeah that's the
problem
they'd have to be escorted like you have
to go we what we would do is we would
escort them out to get back in line for
the neck no frickin skipping theaters I
mean on all serious why have it hasn't
this happened
don't they have smoke shops where you
can go smoke weed isn't there a thing
for that yeah there's like there's like
weed bars now and yeah right there's
weed bars and food edibles and all that
you can go to a place and get some
coffee and edible right we may need to
google it it could exist okay it could
be very much yeah this could be already
be a thing there's probably like the
owner of this some theatres like okay
this is my dick yeah we're gonna sponsor
that's a good sponsor the weed theatre
yeah listen um I want to keep you any
longer Blake I just I really I have a
lot of love for you
this was such a great time in my life
doing workaholics I didn't realize how
important it was to me until my last day
on set and I was like I was brought to
tears like you know but I really thank
you for coming on you're my first guest
absolutely yes what he liked honor yeah
I wanted you to be my first guest this
isn't like I went through the rolodex
and I was like who can I get oh no one I
had it pegged that I wanted you to be my
first guest and it's exciting I'm here
now at all things comedy you're my first
guest on all things comedy and I really
appreciate you coming out hey thanks for
having me man it's my pleasure
and that was episode 9 of riffing with
Griffin my beautiful friend Blake
Anderson came out for me and I
appreciate you guys for listening and I
will see you next time
[Music]